etc nous l'économiste en chef de la
banque nationale stéfane marion bonsoir
et stéphane leblanc fiscaliste et
shenyang bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
on a beau privilège de pouvoir analyser
et expliquer ce budget ensemble la
première chose moi ce qui m'a frappé
stéfane marion puis je lis des quelques
reprises tantôt croissance de 2% du
produit intérieur brut en 2020 sa
demeure la prévision de base dans le
budget est ce qu'on est vraiment chaud
via liste du côté du gouvernement
ça semble ambitieux à la lumière des
récents développements tant au niveau
d'économies mondial avec une économie
canadienne qui est chancelante avec la
chute des prix du pétrole donc dans un
contexte où le canada aura peine à
croître 1 1% cette année avec les
révisions
ce serait étonnant que le québec puisse
obtenir une performance de 2 pour ça
selon votre prévision avoue le québec
s'en va vers une croissance de convier
en 2020 je pense que ce pourrait être de
l'ordre entre 1 et 1.5 pour ça et
évidemment dépendamment de la une
[Musique]
l'évolution ou des dommages économiques
qu'on verra au niveau du corps navire
est ce parce que le ministre dise en
entrevue tentons un point de pourcentage
de pib c'est un milliard de moyens donc
le gouvernement pourrait vraiment être
touchée en termes de croissance
économique si le covan a virus la crise
pétrolière la chute des marchés où je ne
sais trop
la baisse de confiance s'amplifie par
contre là où je rejoins le ministre sait
qu'en termes de résilience de l'économie
québécoise
c'est un peu plus grand dans le contexte
actuel je m'explique dont une baisse des
revenus de 1 milliard sur le pays de
retz chauvé c'est d'un point de
pourcentage par contre des taux
d'intérêt qui sont l'hypothèse où ton
intérêt dans ce budget est très
agressive pour les raisons déjà plus
d'un point de pourcentage plus bas que
ce qui était présenté dans le budget ce
qui donne 300 millions de marge de
manoeuvre dégagées au service de la
dette donc parce que c'est de l'intérêt
en moins qu'on n'aurait pas saigner
comme un élément qu'on pense à trois
puis deux autres choses faut pas oublier
que le québec est un importateur net de
pétrole
or la baisse du prix du pétrole faire en
sorte de faire baisser la facture
énergétique de l'ensemble des québécois
d'à peu près trois milliards cette année
si les prix se maintiennent aux niveaux
actuels donc le des éléments
compensatoires qui nous amène à penser
que nous devrions avoir une croissance
entre 1 et 1.5 pour cent cette année
est ce qu'il ya des éléments stimulateur
de l'économie dans ce budget des
entreprises du secteur des entreprises
d'e mails ya un milliard l'an budget
pour les entreprises où on veut aller
bonifiée avec des investissements
innovations
donc ça c'est un crédit qui va vraiment
être pour
encourager l'acquisition matériel de
fabrication transformation d'équipements
informatiques ou de coach est de coacher
adagio et c'est un crédit qui va
atteindre 10 % pour la région de
montréal à montréal et québec est
également
15 et 20% selon les différents types de
région pour l'économie c'est un
stimulant et je pense qu'avec un taux
qui dit de 10 à 20% rentrent en ligne de
compte la décision de l'entrepreneur qui
décide de faire un investissement
lorsqu'on avait des taux critique pour
sa commune est l'une des dernières
années dans leur décision
la deuxième est pour ça qu au niveau du
crédit je pense que ça va venir
il ya un autre mesure où vas-tu qui
s'appelle la déduction pour la
commercialisation des innovations exact
qu'on veut encourager les entreprises à
innover et xavier à vendre leurs
innovations on nomme encourager les
entreprises à café de la recherche et
développement au québec
donc on sort des produits m'ont
encouragé les entreprises à des
commerciaux dont tout les produits où on
a atteint un niveau où on a un beau
devait ou des logiciels où on a des
droits d'auteurs qu'on peut
s'enregistrer
on va rendre le droit dans le fonds en
fonction du revenu que ça va rapporter à
l'entreprise
on est venu là qui ne calculent quelques
conflits qu'ils qui était intéressant
puisque à dix mais il ya quelques
complexes doit être mais on va dégager
c'est quoi le revenu qui provient de ces
de cette innovation là il serait venu
leur est imposé sa demande pour ça donc
pour une pme qui en 2021 va payer du 4%
erait dû 2% sur ce profil et il en ad
autres entreprises qui perdent 11 11 et
demi pour sa part à 2 2% sur ses montres
avec une hausse des dépenses de 5,1 pour
cent au total avec presque 16 milliards
de plus d'un pic le progrès le plan
québécois des infrastructures 2020 2030
est ce que vous diriez que ce budget va
stimuler l'économie
il va très certainement apporter une
résilience à l'économie du québec qui ne
sera beaucoup moins apparente dans
d'autres provinces
avec le ralentissement potentiel de
l'économie mondiale donc je pense que si
on a donc eu ce budget là arrive en
cette date si parce que qui plus est les
mesures qui avait annoncé à l'automne
dernier vont déployer au deuxième
trimestre pour les allégements fiscaux
notamment l'occasion famille le tarif
qui revient à 1 8 dollar n 5 pour les
autres garderies cdc sens absolu c'est
ce qui fait en sorte que tous on sera
déployé au deuxième trimestre au québec
qui le trimestre le plus vulnérable au
niveau de l'économie nord-américaine
avec les codes qu'on avait russe et non
pas des blocs du blocus sont blancs
exactement on a besoin de notre corps de
certainement stimulée d'économies est ce
que dans les infrastructures moi je
regarde des infrastructures vertes
notamment le transport collectif est ce
qu'on va assez loin en disant on va
prolonger le rêve jusqu'à laval mois
encore mais ça l'étude jusqu'à chambly
saint jean sur richelieu
on continue à prioriser différents
projets à québec à gatineau notamment
est-ce que c'est suffisant de faire ça
de développer les infrastructures et le
transport collectif et l'électrification
en matière environnementale je pense que
si vous voulez changer comportement des
gens c'est très important parce au
public avec l'étalement urbain
on a poussé les gens pour des causes
d'abordabilité c'est très cher habiter
dans la grande région de montréal qui
est beaucoup plus chère qu'auparavant
donc on a poussé les gens avec
totalement urbain ci d'avoir des
systèmes de transport qui rejoignent les
gens je pense que c'est la façon
d'inciter les gens prennent aux
transports en commun à moyen terme fois
ni le transport en commun à leur portée
c'est la réalité l'étalement urbain
on doit en tenir compte et je me suis un
pas dans la bonne direction vous les
économistes vous connaissez bien les
faits du prix sur le comportement des
gens donc pourquoi on va pas plus loin
dans le bonus malus c'est à dire que
d'un côté on incite les gens à changer
leurs comportements
on les encourage c'est la carotte mais
de l'autre le bâton c'est à dire je veux
dire clairement pas en train de vous il
faut remonter des taxes sur l'essence ou
la taxe carbone mais en même temps c'est
une façon de faire changer les
comportements et on le ministre ne veut
pas d'aidé
mais c'est une question qui est posée
par une personne relativement jeunes qui
habitent la grande région de montréal
la réalité c'est que le glissement
population amène le changement de
comportement
il ya une préférence pour des véhicules
sûrs il dit claudie semaine population
la deuxième c'est l'aspect régional avec
l'étalement urbain
les gens peut-être besoin de deux
voitures pour arriver à pouvoir gérer
leur activité mafia mondiale donc
l'aspect régional est très très
important dans ce contexte là je pense
qu'on est pas rendu là et qu'à moyen
terme peut être considéré jamais trop
rapide pour façon dans ce budget tient à
vous rassurer je pose pas des questions
à propos de ma situation personnelle je
le dis on va parler de la situation
personnelle de bien des gens parce que
des crédits intéressant crédit d'impôt
de tam ans pour les personnes nées dans
une étude qui était faite en 2010 les
critiques compliqué présentement il ya
quatre volets donc on veut on vient sans
fil crédit on change de nom on a un
nouveau crédit qui va s'appeler les
crédits de rambo ça pour personne
aidante et là on a deux volets avec
allongée donc on va avoir le droit à
crédit si la personnes cohabitent avec
une personne qui est admissible
avant on le doit un crédit de 1250 et on
peut avoir un crédit additionnel de 1250
selon le revenu de la personne qui était
dit donc c'est la personne aidée à
grandir revenu de moins de 22 mille
dollars il n'y a pas de réduction dont
un drop les montants de 1250 dollars et
ça ça peut nous donner quitus 2500 le
deuxième crédit de 1250 pour les
persiennes et on n'est pas obligé de
cohabiter donc on peut être un internes
actuels pour une personne avec qui on
n'habite pas et on peut avoir le doigt
ce qu'ils disent est il crédible pauvre
le deuxième volet quai pour les aînés de
70 ans et plus long un crédit de 1250
dollars on doit cohabiter ça n'inclut
pas le conjoint donc au projet
deux courtes sur les routes sont les 12
et il est content de l'otan n'a pas
droit qui dit mais on ne doit même de
ses 2250 font cohabiter mais il n'est
pas inutile donc content que le vit la
personne on ne doit que dix autres
mesures qui touchent le portefeuille des
gens ses roues les verts ont parlé
d'environnement l'encouragement
l'incitatif rouler vers demain au
concept pour les verts l'heure où les
verts on avait des motivations qui se
termine le 31 mars 2020 donc ceux qui
veulent aller de l'avant
pas moins de 69 dollars les véhicules
ridicule on parle de 8000 $ de dead à
l'achat dans une situation c'est un 8 8
dollars également 15 à 20 ces trois
villes à 2021 donc à partir du 1er avril
2020 jusqu'à 2020 en 2000 au 31 mars
2021 mais seulement pour les véhicules
de son niveau au niveau de véhicules
d'occasion
cette jusqu'au 31 mars 2000 2020 mais le
dollar s'est moins de 69 à 75
on parle de 4000 $ également et 75 à 125
c mille cinq cents par titre 1er avril
mais le meut laminé sano aussi que les
mesures et les reconduire jusqu'au 31
mars 2010
quand on connaît pas ça va être quoi les
nouvelles dunes de nouvelles
applications à partir du 1er avril 2021
ça va être quoi le nouveau montage magie
qui attend de voir quels seront les
modèles qui sont est en place
donc c'est 1200 sont les 15 dollars pour
l'aide à la conversion des systèmes de
chauffage au mazout
donc on peut avoir un qui est dit de
1200 sont les quinze lui aussi reconduit
jusqu'au 31 mars 2026 et on à 250
dollars également pour la conversion des
chauffe-eau donc qui électriques dont
c'est aussi ça continue ses fins de
marion on s'est posé des questions sur
la viabilité de la croix de précision de
croissance est ce que ça veut dire sur
les finances publiques mais quand on
regarde par exemple les revenus les
dépenses
le surplus budgétaires avant fonds des
générations quand on regarde la réserve
comptable de stabilisation quand on
regarde les surplus des dernières années
la situation financière du québec est
exceptionnel est ce qu'on peut dire ça
on est en plein emploi aussi avec le
tournage qui est le plus bas au canada
et oui effectivement c'est exceptionnel
et ça permet d'avoir les budgets comme
un but aujourd'hui on arrive à augmenter
dépenses mais aussi en même temps d'y
aller avec un aspect structurelle parce
qu'historiquement en insérant comme à la
marge de manoeuvre pour intéresser les
postes clés tels la santé l'éducation et
en plus d'y aller avec le virage
structurel avec des dépenses pour
augmenter la productivité qui nous amène
à penser que oui ya une lumière au bout
du tunnel en termes de l'augmentation de
la croissance potentielle pour pouvoir
conserver les programmes sociaux qu'on
entasse présente donc ça va quand même
prendre des changements ça va prendre
des changements dans la façon de gérer
la croissance des dépenses et des
revenus dans les prochaines années
je pense que l'aspect le virage vers
l'augmentation de la productivité qui ne
peut que s'exécuter à long terme donc
une équipe et d'autres atteignent des
objets qui a trait à long terme déjà
commencé avec kiel 3 énoncé économique
du ministre donc je pense que c'est
c'est sa marque de commerce augmenter la
production à long terme pour permettre
la pérennité des finances publiques et
je pense que c'était moi j'applaudis au
moins ce virage là pour nous permettre
de faire face à tous les vents
contraires on les changements brutaux
qu'on pourrait avoir au cours des
prochaines années que j'entends pas le
mot récession dans votre dans vos mots
une récession arrivera un jour
évidemment
la donne est compliquée avec le cas du
coronavirus mais j'ai bon espoir que
cette année la récession sera évitée au
québec et un mot sur la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale
noda le seul réseau social il ya eu des
consultations avec entre autres
lee le secteur résidentiel de
construction avec les gens de
construction donc on s'attend avec ce
qui était dans le budget parce qu' une
solution technologique qui souhaite
implanter pour éviter le travail au noir
dans le domaine de la construction
résidentielle
donc un jour peut-être de neige qu'on
avait comment nous faire dans le domaine
et restauration
notre technologie poe la main mais c'est
clair que ça il ya des idiots de
l'argent dans les budgets où on va aller
chercher 1 150 millions de table de
mettre en place cette mesure là donc il
faut contrer le travail au noir demande
constitution les anciens stéphane
leblanc stéfane marion merci pour cette
analyse ce soir merci merci beaucoup